it is Friday I'm Dave rubben and we have
uh two of my favorite guests we're just
diving right in host of the Michael
Noles show over on The Daily wire Mr
Michael nolles and also from the daily
wire uh we have Andrew claven whose new
book The House of Love and Death a
Cameron winter mystery uh is out now
Andrew am I correct is it out now or did
we oh no we get you in a couple days
August 31st if I'm not mistaken oober
October 31st right but available to
pre-order right this moment while we're
talking you could be pre-ordering oer
not pre-ordering them guys I don't know
it's been a very stressful week uh even
read even reading a teleprompter has
become difficult at this point anyway
it's it's a pleasure to have both of you
on obviously uh it's been a crazy week
for everybody and I wanted to have two
people uh who are on the short list of
kind of political talkers that haven't
completely lost their minds but there
was actually another specific reason
that I wanted to have you guys on
because Andrew you are Christian and
Michael you are Catholic and I am Jewish
and I thought that would be an
interesting little combination to
discuss what is going on in the Holy
Land right now so before we get to any
of kind of the specifics on the ground
stuff and all the horrors and all that I
thought maybe we could talk for a moment
about why the Holy Land either is or is
not important to you uh Andrew why don't
I let you go first and you have a really
in Story related to your faith yeah I'm
I'm a I was born raised a Jew and I
became a Christian I was always a
secular Jew and it was only through
Christianity that I became deeply
connected uh to my to my jewishness
oddly enough but I've never lost my
sense of Pride at being a Jew and I've
never lost my sense of connection to the
Jewish people and the one time that I
was actually in Israel I was struck by
just the reality of the Gospel scenes
and I mean one of the things that
happens when you visit is you think oh
those are the you know mountains that
Jesus looked at these are the places
where he had his footsteps actually were
and and one of the things that was very
difficult for me to overcome was
centuries of some
Christians both philosophical and active
anti-Semitism and I had to come to
understand how I could believe what I
believed which was in Christ crucified
how I could believe that without
abandoning my people without abandoning
my app absolute sense that these are
God's people and that God has played out
the drama of his interaction with
Humanity through the history of the Jews
which I still believe is quite true and
a lot of the things that people have
falsely believed over the years that
Christianity has somehow replaced the
Jews or that you know the stupidest
thing that anyone has ever said the Jews
killed Christ are based on a
misunderstanding uh of the fact that
this is the theater of God's
relationship the Jews are the theater of
God's relationship and when you see
people who hate the Jews and I don't
care what anybody says in each specific
case of Jew hatred there's always some
specific reason that people pull out
it's always the hatred of God it's
always the hatred of God underneath that
it's the hatred of uh someone who wants
us to be better than we feel we are who
wants us to deny some of our Basic
Instincts and basic drives in order to
reach for something that is more like
his image those are the things that the
Jews have uh imposed upon us uh that to
make us better and to make us more holy
and we're ticked off about it and uh you
know n even said this n basically said
you know that the thing he hated about
Christianity was that it was the slave
religion of the Jews because it elevated
not the winners but the losers it
elevated the people who loved instead of
hated who believed in love instead of
power so all of these things this
relationship between Jews and Christians
is unbroken it's an unbroken thread and
at the best I think Christians are able
to say that they've been grafted on to
this great history uh and have become a
part of it and you can tell they've
become a part of it because now they're
persecuted too but but I cannot cannot
look upon the things that are going on
in Israel without believing that this is
part of what's happening in our society
I think we all have felt the evil Rising
we all have felt the madness and the
lies and the self-deceptions and the
idolatry Rising all around us in every
country and that it should come out in
Bloodshed against the Jews shouldn't be
any surprise at all that has been
happening now for centuries and it will
continue to happen I think until this
history has its conclusion which we all
believe is going to be a happy ending
but not for a while uh Michael it's
going to be tough to top your colleague
right there but I I I do want to say one
thing quickly first which is Andrew you
know it's interesting you said that
about you know that Jesus Took these
steps in these Hills because we were I
took my whole team to Israel uh about 6
months ago and we were in Judea and
Samaria which is what is now known
unfortunately as the West Bank it's just
the West Bank of the Jordan River but it
was Judea and Samaria part of the
Eternal nation of Israel where the Jews
defended the macbes defended their land
against the Greek Invaders it's the
story of Hanukkah and we had this tour
guide who was walking around showing us
those those it's those Hills right there
and then I had this strange moment where
I was like wait a minute this this story
of Hanukkah we light the candles you get
you get some gifts you eat something
fried and it's like that story has been
told for thousands and thousands of
years and you people seem to think that
the Jews have nothing to do with this
land it's rather extraordinary noes now
I'm gonna let you try to beat claven
somehow sadly I've never even been to
the Holy Land but I was I was trying to
explain to some friends why it is that
we care about the Holy Land you know I
we were previously talking about the war
in Ukraine and I don't really care that
much about Ukraine I don't want innocent
people to suffer I don't want to see
Injustice but I don't feel any
connection to Ukraine I do feel a
connection to the Holy Land though I've
never been there everybody feels some
kind of connection to the Holy Land
whether they're Consciousness conscious
of it or not and so that's why these uh
conflicts can have such Global
consequences uh Drew hit the nail on the
head when he said that Christians view
the story from the ancient Jews of the
Old Testament up through today as a
continuity and so the the the word that
keeps cropping up in these debates is
over Zionism you know what is the nature
of Zionism and the the historical
theological claim of Zionism is that
because the the Jews had the Holy Land
thousands of years ago then they were
kicked out by the Romans in 70 AD they
still have a legal claim to the land
that's kind of the hard theological
historical claim of Zionism uh
Christians generally do not believe that
because Christians View and the church
has traditionally viewed herself as the
Fulfillment of the Old Testament the New
Testament fulfills the old the old
predicts the new so the church is the
new Israel Christ is the new Adam Mary
is the new Arc of the Covenant you know
Mary is the new Eve um so where where
does that leave the Jews uh the as a
historical matter you know in the 19th
century you see the rise of Zionism as a
movement among Jews with other
nationalist movements 1848 was the year
of revolutions you had Revolution
nationalist Revolutions in Italy France
Germany Belgium Switzerland Sweden all
over the place and you had the beginning
of this nationalist movement among the
Jewish people who wanted their own
Homeland and this takes form in 1897
with Theodore Herzel who initially was
going to bring the Jews to British East
Africa and then that kind of got shot
down be very strange to have Jews
wandering around British East Africa so
you know brings them back to the holy
land after the bfor Declaration in 1917
and then the establishment of the modern
state of Israel in 1948 and here we are
all fighting over this and the reason I
bring up all of that long history is
because it help helps to explain why BLM
is echoing the talking points of Hamas
why we hear this DEC colonizer rhetoric
and how we need to liberate the
oppressed from the oppressors and all
this the reason is because the modern
nation state of Israel came to be in a
very similar way to which our own Nation
came to be which is it it came about as
a result of the British Empire because
of a growth of nationalist feelings uh
and uh that's why so many of our enemies
seem to be the same enemies and so when
that question of Zionism comes up people
will say can a Christian be a Zionist
the Catholic Church hasn't answered that
question ex directly exactly Tot but uh
the church viewing herself as the new
Israel could not ascribe to a hard
Zionism in principle but in practice I
think we look around and we say first of
all there's obviously no justification
for the Hamas attacks on civilians uh
there's obviously no justification for
so much of what the Palestinian
Representatives have done um so as a
Prudential matter now that we are where
we are 70 years after the establishment
of the state of Israel who do you feel
better with looking after the Holy Land
yes you know the Jews or Hamas and I
don't think that's a very difficult
question you know it's so interesting
because again having just been there uh
the the five days that we did in
Jerusalem we our first 5 days and I just
and I I've been there before but I just
could not get over how peaceful it was
in jerus
and women in traditional Muslim Garb on
the same bus with you know Orthodox
Jewish boys and every combination of
that that you can imagine and yes Israel
does defend the holy sites of all of the
major religions and the bahai and
everybody else which it's a far cry from
what was going on before Israel got
control of Jerusalem uh but I want to
start with a tweet from you Michael
because you just mentioned BLM and and
one of the things I've been trying to
unfurl all week is is exactly what you
just said how these movements here are
so connected that it does not surprise
me that people who think boys are girls
also can't make a moral uh stance on
whether a woman being burned alive is
okay or not uh you had a tweet about
that uh you wrote BLM would gleefully do
to all of us what Hamas just did to the
Jews that has always been the case but
some people couldn't see it be sure to
send these endorsements to all of your
friends who posted that stupid black
Square on social media a few years ago
uh I'm very proud to say that obviously
no one on this panel fell for that
nonsense but Michael I'll let you chime
in again quick because it was your Tweet
um how much money like the amount of
money that probably got funded for Hamas
on this stuff it's just it's so
extraordinary of course this to me is
the meaning of Israel's enemies or
America's enemies which literally is not
true but broadly is true uh there there
are big divergencies between Israeli
foreign policy and American foreign
policy we saw this recently in Israel's
support for azerbijan over the Armenian
in in the conflict in aan uh but what it
what the meaning of that phrase is is
that the arguments against the modern
nation state of Israel are the arguments
against America and they are the
arguments against Western Civilization
broadly and so even if you don't I care
very much about the holy land and I like
the Jews very much but even if you don't
even if you don't care about any of that
stuff do not think that this is going to
be isolated over in the Middle East this
exact argument this battle is coming to
a place near you in fact it's already
here well that's the crazy thing I mean
I'm watching these rallies if you guys
saw the one that's looked like a modern
Nazi rally in Dearborn Michigan with
thousands of Palestinian flags being
waved and they're you know praising
Hamas and all that it's like do you guys
think you're indigenous to the land that
is the United States they're they're
telling you what they're going to do to
the rest of us uh Andrew I I suppose
that doesn't surprise you that a radical
left movement was going to ultimately be
siding with people who were were burning
babies alive you're you're a student of
History obviously no it doesn't surprise
me in the least and it doesn't surprise
me that it's centered on Israel all the
the rhetoric the rhetoric is so
interesting because they they call
Israel an apartheid state which is
hilarious in a place where a Muslim can
become and has become over a hundred
times a member of the knesset the
Israeli Parliament where uh Muslims
serve in equal status throughout the
country where Supreme Court the the
Supreme Court when the hour prayer shows
up if you're walking down a street in
Jerusalem Muslims lay out their prayer
mats you know on the curb and start
praying right there compare that to Iran
where the the few remaining Jews are
clinging to life too poor to leave and
just hopeful that they're not being
persecuted out of existence same thing
is true of Christians in in several
Muslim countries and then this thing
about colonialism uh there was a tweet
I'm sure you heard about of a a
freelance writer sent out where she said
well this you know what what you fools
what did you think she happily C
celebratory in a celebratory tone she
said what do you think anticolonialism
was going to look like did you think was
just going to be you know a fun thing no
this is how we do anti-colonialism and
it was retweeted by one of the top
columnists at the Washington Post Karen
AIA and the the thing about colonialism
Israel is not a Colonial Country uh you
know if you think about it major Powers
have colonies in smaller places so
France had colonies England has Colony
you know Germany had colonies who are
the colonizers in Israel the Jews are
indigenous people of that region and the
only people who have a written record of
having established a kingdom in that
region and in coming home uh and
declaring themselves I I mean I I differ
with Michael on this I I first don't
think that the church is the new Israel
I think that they are grafted on to
Israel I think it is one in the same
thing and I I think that there's there's
no replacement going on this is this is
predicted in the Book of Revelation that
Israel was going to return it seems to
me to be a major miracle in which case
Hamas is in big trouble because it's
meant to be but I think that this this
idea these terms that they use these
lying dishonest terms apartheid and uh
colonialism are are meant to the fact
that they are used to define Israel is
is indicative of how dishonest this
movement is that it's not really a
movement in favor of indigenous people
because the Jews are indigenous to that
region it's not really a movement
against apartheid because the true
apartheid is really in some of the
Muslim countries surrounding it it's a
movement against Western Liberty against
Western Freedom which itself grows out
of the Jewish Christian tradition it is
the Jews and only the Jews who were told
not to have a king because it was an
offense to God it is the Christians and
only the Christians who have talked
about the sacredness of the individual
these are things that come down to us
these are press legacies handed down to
us by these faiths and it's that that
they hate it's is there isn't there a
fast talking Jew that I think works with
you guys who wrote a book about that
connection from Jerusalem to Athens and
how that I can't stand that guy I know
no just
just was it Walsh I forget I forget who
it was some fast talking Jew I don't
know what yes walz yeah yeah great great
Point obviously uh Andrew I want to
bring up something that Andrew you you
found this video on Twitter you saw this
and you wrote C eloquent accurate so
this is video of NBA legend Amari stamar
he's a multiple time Allstar he actually
converted to Judaism later in life moved
to Israel he was teaching uh sorry he
was coaching one of the Israeli
basketball teams I'm not sure if he's
living in Israel at the moment but he
had a uh a nice little video on what's
going on and and relating it to BLM and
everything we're talking about I woke up
man this morning with some disturbing
news out of Israel that Hamas
kidnapping children putting them in
cages killing women killing the elderly
that's some cowards that's cowardly and
for all y'all black lives matter who
ain't saying nothing well let me figure
out exactly what happened before I say
anything you figure out what it ain't
never been cool to kidnap kids and put
them in cages ain't never been cool to
kill women and and elderly never being
no matter where you from what you
represent what tribe you for don't
matter Michael is it such a a sign of
the times that I'm getting more astute
political analysis and and forget like
I'm getting more like basic truth let's
say from Amari stmy who I used to watch
play basketball than say pretty much
anyone on mainstream media and certainly
on Hamas TV which some people know as
MSNBC and and certainly from The New
York Times the editor of of which was or
one of the editors of which was was ret
tweeting this defense of decolonization
meaning the kidnapping of kids and rape
and murder of civilians it it is a sign
of our times it's a sign of many times
but it's a sign of our times because
we're we're living in a time where our
Elite are extremely corrupt and ignorant
and stupid so during times such as that
uh Ordinary People are going to make a
lot more sense and uh it's it's during
times like that that that you see the
proof of Bill Buckley's quote from 60 70
years ago which was he would rather be
governed by the first 2,000 people in
the Boston phone book than the faculty
of Harvard College I mean just look
Harvard had 30 plus student
organizations signing a letter basically
defending Hamas so if you want sense
Harvard would be the last place to look
Andrew do you think there is a silver
lining here like the the the horrors and
the barbarity and the medieval style
killings which we're still just finding
out about like it's just off the charts
that they may and the fact that they
intentionally wanted people to see it
right the the the Nazis hid their stuff
they documented it because they thought
they were going to be the winners and
they wanted a record not because they
wanted the world to see uh but because
of the severity of this and the fact
that they've gone ahead and put this out
on social media and and even now are
threatening to you know kill some of the
uh some of the hostages and and air that
that it has woken up some people in a
way that maybe they wouldn't have been
woken up otherwise just us talking about
sanity kind of doesn't hit with
everybody yeah that's right I I hesitate
to call it a lining because while good
does often come out of evil the evil
doesn't go away and none of those lives
can be recovered and none of that
tragedy will be erased by any good that
comes out of it but yes I do think that
people looked at these things and saw
these things and suddenly thought wait a
minute wait a minute you can't
intellectualize this away that's why I
retweeted that stoom video because of
its Simplicity you know I thought I I
turned to a you know it really only
takes the slightest spark of human
decent
flickering dimly inside you to look at
the things that we have seen and think
oh those are the bad guys I get that
those are the bad guys and anything else
is better than that because this is evil
so the fact that as Michael points out
30 plus in uh organizations at Harvard
did not have enough human decency left
to spot that shows you that
intellectualization can take you right
through the truth into a very very dark
place so this is a simple thing once you
see this once you accept it once you
actually face what's happening you
realize okay you know there there may be
plenty of questions that have to be
answered in the Middle East but one of
them isn't whether or not we should
exterminate an entire nation of people
that people have tried to exterminate
many many times before that's not an
open question that's a closed question
we know the answer to that the answer is
no don't do that that's evil and so yes
I do think that the fact that it's now
come down to this kind of kindergarten
Simplicity that even even someone who
goes to at least a college below the
level of the ivy league would be able to
see that this is bad a bad thing and I
think the fact one one of the things
that amused me in a grim way was that
many of the people who supported Hamas
and these atrocities at Harvard took
their names off that when it when they
realized it could cost them a job so not
only are they have they signed on to
evil they don't even have the courage of
their evil convictions they're actually
wimpy evil people which is the worst
possible thing you can be I know you'd
think if you were so moral and so just
in your cause and so against colonialism
and everything you'd want everyone to
know but apparently that's not the case
Michael I want to shift slightly to to
the protest that we've seen all over the
world and I I do believe this is a loud
crazy minority I don't think it's most
people have actually been it's been sort
of nice seeing so many people rally
around Israel but there's always going
to be this contingent but what do you
think I mean we're all free speech guys
we're all First Amendment guys obviously
and we believe in Law and Order but what
do we do with a segment of the
population either in America or just
before we started I heard that France is
now Banning Pro Palestinian uh uh
rallies what do we do with segments of
society that will gleefully cheer for
genocide without without shredding our
founding documents you're you're
speaking my language because while I'm a
great defender of the First Amendment
and the I know what I'm asking you I
know what I'm asking you you know I mean
you sort of teed me up for it it I think
that the the way to defend our first
amendment and free speech in the
American tradition is to put a little
emphasis on the tradition part and a
little less emphasis on the abstract
part because Free Speech has come in
recent years to mean something
completely different than it did at the
time of James Madison and Thomas
Jefferson uh so uh today uh the example
I often go back to is before the middle
of the 20th century if you were in a
school you could teach the Bible but you
couldn't teach pornography today if
you're in a public school you can teach
pornography but you're not allowed to
teach the Bible and so something has
really shifted here and what's shifted
is our standards so I'm I'm not even
suggesting that we pass a law against
the pro Hamas protesters in the streets
uh though similar laws have been passed
and enforced in American history but I'm
not I'm not even suggesting that I'm
suggesting that we recognize that a an
important question for a country that
has free speech is not merely can we say
something but what ought we to say
because free speech in the abstract
doesn't mean anything to people who
don't have something to say and so
Rashida TB to me is the perfect example
of this Rashida TB is the picture of the
modern American left outside of her
official Congressional office she has
four Flags she has the Palestine flag
she has Michigan and Detroit Flags
that's nice and then she's got the LGBT
rainbow flag notice any flag that's
missing there uh there's one that seems
kind of important the flag of I can also
see two with genocidal Maniacs uh who
love it I'm not talking about Michigan
and Detroit
yeah although Detroit these days is not
looking great either but but uh I think
it was stenny Hoyer a very powerful
Democrat in Congress who said well
Rashida Talib has every right to have
that flag there it doesn't connote
support for terrorism I'm talking about
the Palestine flag doesn't connote
support for terrorism and she herself is
Palestinian and I guess he's right the
Palestine flag does not necessarily
connote support for terrorism it it sure
seems to very often but it doesn't
necessarily my issue is not that her
flag and her office is Palestinian my
issue is that a US politician is flying
the flag of a foreign Nation at a
government office at a non- diplomatic
office that seems completely insane to
me especially to the exclusion of the
American flag how should that be changed
by passing a law I'm not saying we pass
a law but the Congress should not allow
that local communities should should not
remain neutral to to important questions
of expression and specifically to
pressing moral issues because there's
really no neutrality in the Public
Square and as we conservatives have
pretended that there is we've merely
seeded the Public Square and the
political order to the radicals by the
way I'll go a step further than you I
mean when when the when we had pride
month which basically takes 364 days a
year um I am completely I am completely
against that Invader flag being put up
at any of our embassies or buildings or
White House which at the White House
they put it above the American flag
which also is a violation of of certain
codes like it's flod yeah the flag
certain codes the flag code man it's
been a
week let's get to some of the political
response on some of this stuff uh Tucker
Carlson who of course is no longer with
Fox and he's doing the show on X
formerly Twitter I suppose uh he was
very critical of Nikki Haley on some of
her comments responding to these attacks
so there's a lot at stake in how we
encourage Israel to respond to the
horrifying Hamas attacks wisdom and
long-term thinking are essential but you
will not be surprised to learn that is
not what we are getting watch this
person for example who happens to be the
media's pick for president of the United
States this is not just an attack on
Israel this is an attack on America
because they hate us just as much and
what we have to understand is this is
the reason that we have to unite around
making sure our enemies do not hurt our
friends America can never be so arrogant
to think we don't need friends just like
we needed them on 911 that's why Ukraine
needs us when Russia's doing this that's
why Israel needs us when Hamas and Iran
are doing this and I'll say this to to
prime minister Netanyahu finish them
finish them Hamas did this you know
Iran's behind it finish them they should
have hell to pay for what they've just
done this was an attack on America she
says when in fact it was not and for
that reason we must quote finish Iran a
nation of nearly 90 million people
people what are we watching here this is
not sober leadership she's a child and
this is the Tantrum of a child ignorant
sure bloodthirsty yet no one in
Washington scolded her for it in fact
they aped her
hysteria I have to say and it slightly
pains me to say this I'm really
disappointed in Tucker right now and and
Ben that guy that we mentioned before
over ear Network he really went off on
Tucker and I shared it I think it was
right look I I'm with you Michael
especially on this one the Ukraine thing
it makes no sense we have poured money
and and it's just insane there this is a
completely different situation but
Tucker said a couple things there that
make no sense to me first off I have
never heard anyone anyone say that Nikki
Haley is the darling of the media I mean
just I've never heard anyone say that
period uh and secondly this wasn't an
attack on America except how many
Americans were killed I think at least
11 and I think they have 22 American
hostages right now which as far as I
know we haven't even demanded back I
mean if you kill 11 Americans is that
not an attack on America at the very
least that doesn't mean we just go in
and bomb the place to high hell but I
think he's playing a bit of a
duplicitous game Here Andrew what do you
think yeah no there's no question about
it first of all you could tell from what
Nikki Ali was saying that she wasn't
saying finish Iran she was saying finish
AAS who is backed by Iran so he
willfully misunderstood her uh you know
the opposite of neoc conservativism this
idea that we should fight every war
everywhere is isolationism and both of
those are childish and the evidence that
Tucker Carlson has subscribe to the
childishness of isolationism is that his
argument against going into Ukraine was
that Putin really wasn't as bad a guy as
we thought he was and he wasn't really
our enemy that's the one argument you
can't make for not going into Ukraine
you can make all kinds of argument all
kinds of good reasons to stay out of
Ukraine or limit the amount of support
we give to Ukraine or be careful about
Ukraine all kinds of arguments the fact
that Putin is a sweetheart is not one of
them the man is a gangster he is a
genuine enemy of this country as well as
anybody decent anywhere and he killed
you know people who disagree with him
even if they live in other countries we
have to oppose him but how much is a
fair question the same thing is true
here yes of course an attack on Israel
is not an attack on America sometimes
Israel's uh interests and America's
interests diverge but an attack on our
best ally in the Middle East is a moment
for reflection and consideration of what
we should do we don't have any other
friends any real friends in the Middle
East except for Israel and it is an
important wedge that we have got into a
very very troubled area from which a lot
of War uh tends to come so I just
thought Tucker that was just bad
reasoning it was drum beating and it was
uh basically uh trying to stir up the
America First crowd I I really was not
uh thrilled with it at all yeah and I
think I can speak for all of us but
correct me if I'm wrong like we all like
Tucker I I've played clips of him all
the time I think he's right on like 95%
of the stuff I just think there's this
weird and and and Michael about the the
Americans that were killed like what
would be a declaration of war on America
I'm not saying we should declare war on
Iran I do agree with Nikki Haley that
Israel has to do whatever it has to do
everyone else is allowed to win a war
and they should win a war against the
enemy that's trying to kill them but
what do you what do you make of the
oddness of not mentioning that yes a
whole bunch of Americans were killed and
are still captive right now I I'll go a
little softer on Tucker Carlson uh but
I'll I'll reframe it from from Nikki
Hal's comments because it it might well
be the case she was talking about Hamas
not talking about finishing the Iranian
regime but other people like Lindsey
Graham our call well so yeah we'll get
to that we'll get to Lindsay in a second
do you want me to you know why don't I
play the clip why don't I play the clip
right now and then you can address that
okay so here's Tucker talking about
Lindsay Graham and Dan crenchaw here's
fellow neocon Lindsey Graham just
spelling it out and calling for the
bombing of Iran so I've been on the
phone all day to the midd East and I've
told our allies and people with
connections to Iran what I would do I
would tell Iran that if hesah attacks
Israel we're going to come after you the
Iranians and have a coordinated effort
between the United States and Israel to
put Iran out of the Oil Business by
destroying their refineries their four
major refineries in Iran their fixed
targets if Hezbollah attacks Israel I
would make Iran p a heavy price what
exactly would happen to the United
States if we declared war on Iran and
started blowing up their infrastructure
Lindsey Graham has no clue what would
happen he hasn't thought it through he's
almost 70 years old and he has no
children he doesn't care but neither
amazingly do most of his colleagues in
Washington they're as Reckless as he is
Texas Congressman Dan Crenshaw took to
social media to call for what he
described as a war to end all wars as if
there is such a thing but of course
there isn't such a thing Wars beget more
war the bigger the conflict the uglier
and longer lasting the consequences see
World War I for
details ah no I'm going to let you chime
in but he's doing a couple things there
some Wars do end things World War II
ended horrible things it doesn't end all
wars uh but also yes I I'm completely in
agreement that what Lindsay said there
but that's very different than what
Nikki said Lindsay said something
completely different Nikki was clearly
saying take out Hamas that's very
different than saying blow up
Iran the the the connection between the
two I think is is why in many ways
Lindsey Graham has the clearer argument
on this which and it's an argument that
Israel's making which is Iran is obvious
viously behind the the Hamas attacks and
so if you want to take if you want to
take out the problem you've really got
to weaken Iran and so it's a case where
regime change in Iran is clearly in
Israel's interest regime change in Iran
might be in the American interest but
I'm not totally convinced of that and
I'm not necessarily convinced of that
right now where so many recent regime
change Wars have not been in America's
interest regime change in Iraq regime
change in Libya regime change in Egypt
uh and especially when we're at this
moment of uh we were already on the
brink of World War III I mean the first
major war in Europe since World War II
it should give us all a little bit of
pause especially as that conflict in
which the United States is effectively a
belligerent because we're the only
reason Ukraine can keep fighting uh has
brought Russia and China two of our
enemies closer together that's a little
nerve-wracking you see uh xiin ping
already starting to saber rattle in the
South China Sea and Taiwan what would it
mean if the United States declared war
on Iran right now you've already got
Lebanon effectively entering into the
war because hezb is entering Israel from
the north uh you know a a regional
conflict coupled with another regional
conflict could very quickly spiral out
of control into a third world war at
which point china obviously goes into
Taiwan so now you've got fighting
basically all around the globe and it's
it's Why without getting into the
specifics on Tucker maybe he's
overstating it maybe he's
misrepresenting what Nikki Haley said I
I do agree with the broad point which is
the the American interest right now in
Israel and the facts are changing by the
minute is to contain the war to keep
this as a a regional war that will end
as quickly as possible is that likely to
happen I'm not so sure uh but I I don't
think that uh it would be in the
interest of the United States for us to
escalate things by the way for the
record I actually do agree with that
which is why I sort of agree with Nikki
which is that you go in there you do
whatever I've said it a lot of times
this week so I'm going to say it again
you got to do whatever the you got
to do right now after what has justed
and you eliminate Hamas and you and if
you have to deal with bombs in the north
and what that means withb but yeah the
Iran thing I do view as a different
thing even though it's deeply connected
guys I don't feel we can end the show
this way how do we how do we end a week
like this how do we Clen what are you up
to this
weekend well I'll be I'll be visiting
family so I hope and dodging obviously
dodging the uh Jihad the Friday Jihad to
visit family I'll be uh phoning I'll be
tweeting his address so they can find
him and and distract distract the
terrorists uh and put them where they
should be I'm pretty sure you just
called your family jihadis I'm gonna be
visiting family and dodging the
jihadists dod or maybe I'll be visiting
jihadis and dodging my family I'm not
sure it all depends how things go but
listen I I think the important thing you
really are right about this day the
important thing is that you know you
enjoy uh every moment and enjoy the
things that we have here which are so
amazingly great even now at one of our
low points in my lifetime this country
is still a great place to be and uh and
remember the values that made it that
way and you know we'll move on listen
there's always hope and I I am actually
very hopeful that we'll pull through
this it's just going to be ugly for a
while and it's been set up to be this
way by our weak and uh Reckless
Administration but hopefully that too
will pass noes he makes it tough to
follow but I'm GNA give you the final
word before we head out for the weekend
I want to follow it I want to follow it
with
uh by by linking my activities to Drew's
because look Drew I'm going up to New
York I figured there's no better way to
celebrate the Day of jihad and by being
in the Big Apple and so I hope that we
all make it out safe but if not if we
all go up in a fiery Blast from some
Jihadi I hope that it happens while you
and I are having Martinis in Manhattan
Somewhere over the weekend sounds look
you guys look at you guys with your
martinis last time you both were at my
house I tried to make claven drink some
fancy tequila he almost spit in my face
can't he can't do it he can't you
conservatives with your brown liquor all
right guys it was a pleasure as always
I'm I'm uh I'm truly I mean this I'm
proud to be in the fight with you guys I
thank everybody for watching there's
there's no postgame show today I've got
a couple things that I have to take care
of uh part two with Megan Kelly who's
also on that short list of uh talkers
that make some sense is up right now
across platforms and we'll clo we'll
cold close you with uh something de for
the weekend I leave it up to my team all
right
CIA I I'm asked all the time so Dennis
are you optimistic or pessimistic and
this is my not only the answer I give
people but it's what I believe but of
course I tell people what I believe so I
shouldn't have had to add that uh but in
any event I say you know what I'm I'm
not particularly interested in either
optimism or pessimism because ironically
they both can serve a negative purpose
The Optimist thinks everything will turn
out well why fight the pessimist thinks
everything will turn out lousy why fight
I never ask if I'm optimistic or
pessimistic I ask what do I have to do
and the answer is fight that is the only
question that
[Applause]
matters